[Música]
eu ia dividir com vocês algumas
perguntas que me acompanham e talvez
acompanha muitos de vocês ficam mais
simples e você faz esses podem confiar a
curiosidade atrás dessa pergunta qual é
o seu trabalho qualquer sua habilidade
em qualquer profissão quanto você ganha
qualquer curiosidade as pessoas às vezes
resume essa resposta dizendo que elas
são a eu sou médico eu sou contador eu
sou estudante eu sou cabeleireiro
eu sou mark teto o risco dessa resposta
simples e curta e rápida
a pessoa que escuta enquadrar você e
limitado naquilo que ela entende porque
é um cabeleireiro que é ser empreendedor
que quer ser um arquiteto
eu tenho um amigo já falecido querido
amigo osvaldo oliveira
ele responde a essa pergunta quando
falava osvaldo e você faz ele responde
eu faço o que eu posso
essa resposta é muito libertador né
então o que ele pode então começam um
diálogo né ea é inspirado nos valdo
liberar hoje em dia respondeu certo que
você faça o que eu posso por tudo aquilo
que me importa é que ele enfrente com
mais algumas questões familiares já
ouviram isso não sei de onde pegou um
pouco de ansiedade essa cessão desses
planetas eu sou dessa cidade
a solução de uma empresa se eu sou
funcionário público seu trabalho pra
alguém né
à minha volta eu sou de tantos lugares
né é vontade de falar mas eu sou de onde
eu sou eu sou da nas minhas brincadeiras
de rua em copacabana na minha infância
eu sou do cheiro das tintas que a minha
volta para pintar suas telas em casa
eu sou do amor pelas águas eu sou dessa
música que a gente cria em conjunto essa
música circular essa música coletiva
eu sou das aquarelas eu sou do time das
pessoas que acredita mais em cooperação
do que competição ea mas para abreviar o
sindicato me perguntam sérgio é de onde
falou do tráfico ou no tráfego de lsd e
aquele aquela paralisada
eu sou traficante de leveza e
simplicidade e diversão
achei uma droga incrível para sobreviver
no mundo que não tá neve não está
simples não está divertindo
e cada vez que torna a minha vida ea
vida de um pequeno grupo de uma pessoa
um pouquinho mais leve um pouquinho mais
simples um pouquinho mais divertida é a
sensação de que eu fiz o melhor que
tinha a ser feito
às vezes eu respondo também que buscando
respostas que saiam desse lugar comum é
você é de onde eu sou da compostagem é
só a composteira humana desligar essa eu
tenho cara de otimista não venha mas não
sou otimista sobre recente mesmo tem um
lado meu pessimista explicando muita
coisa do que eu tô vendo acompanhando
escutando não me agrada muita coisa
sobre internet sair na rua tem muita
coisa que me incomoda mas eu descobri um
jeito de processar de alguma forma essas
coisas que me desagrada e entregar
alguma coisa pequena e valiosa
ou seja sou pessimista com meus olhos
extremistas que os meus ouvidos
mas quando eu abro a boca quando eu
tenho a chance de interagir de fazer
alguma coisa eu carrego com muito
otimismo
às vezes ingenuamente eleições
genuinamente otimista
enfim vamos avançar essa história essa
aqui é matadora essa pergunta você faz
gente fazendo terapia há anos para uma
resposta satisfatória para essa pergunta
fazendo da igreja fazendo coaching
fazendo workshops de propósito
fazendo retiro sabático caminho de
compostela para achar uma resposta para
isso
se vou ser sincero a melhor resposta
para quem é você as seguintes é quem é
você e eu sou criador tipo deus não
menos 6 quase deus nós somos todos
dotados dessa massa de até poder de
criar o tempo inteiro tudo que está
acontecendo aqui não é fruto de criação
você está criando conexões desse teatro
toda a criação do evento
a minha fala sendo criada com vocês já
dois meses que estou criando isso a
gente criar a gente vai sair daqui a
gente vai criar conexões vão criar
futuros planos
passamos o tempo inteiro criando acho
que essa seja talvez a nossa maior
vocação são os criadores
só tem um detalhe zinho pra você assume
a boca e falar que você
criador do criador você tem que ser sem
vergonha sem vergonha de falar essas
coisas sem vergonha de ser quem você é
sem vergonha de se expressar
serve grande no parecer ridículo sem
vergonha de arriscar sem vergonha de
cair de começar tudo de novo sem
vergonha de dizer sim você ligou a dizer
não dizer eu te amo dizer vou embora
você vê inclusive disse sentir vergonha
se fosse não fossem vergonha estaria lá
dentro com vergonha de entrar aqui pra
enfrentar uma conversa com um vitória
enorme
ela é minha pergunta é a seguinte por
que será que convidaram pra esse evento
o traficante sem vergonha
aí eu fiquei me perguntando o que eu vou
levar contra a minha boa idéia é
compartilhar não te deixes então queria
dividir com vocês um segredinho e fique
aqui entre a gente uma intimidade
minha sensação é de que eu não tenho
nada aqui dentro é que não tem nada eu
tenho pensamento eu tenho planos eu
tenho memórias eu tenho sentimentos em
um monte de idéias
faça uma porção de coisas mas não são
coisas que eu posso dizer que estão aqui
dentro
elas passam por mim e eu gosto desse
vazio
eu gosto desse nada eu demorei um tempo
para entender que é destinada esse
estado a 100 de disponibilidade de 100
sido assim a ser afetado pelo mundo que
têm surgido muita coisa que eu sou e que
eu faço então não é nada como a gente
escuta quer unidade a ausência de alguma
coisa incompetência é um vazio que é
criativo tem cartão de visita àqueles
que as pessoas trocam botar no bolso em
um dia vou ligar pra vocês
você tem isso eu tive os meus cartões já
teve vários cartões sempre lá com o meu
nome
algum título arquiteto e urbanista josé
bueno consultor em inovação josé bueno
professor educador diretor de um
instituto chamado harmonia educação e
sustentabilidade
mas chega uma hora que essas palavras
elas não representavam por completo
eu resolvi achar o símbolo para traduzir
melhor um símbolo de uma ponte
o desenho mesmo que fala bastante quem
eu sou eu sou das conexões é só das
travessias
eu sou da arte e da arquitetura eu
comecei a me apresentar com um cartão
com uma imagem uma metáfora mas pra ver
nos agrada às pessoas elas não dava
muita bola a ponte sempre virava para
ter uma informação mais concreta é mais
real do que eu faço do que eu sou é onde
me achar
e eu também sou vingativo gente vai
fazendo um cartão novo
hoje eu me apresento o meu cartão zin
pela ponte entrego eu espero quanto
tempo ela vai levar olhando a ponte logo
ela vira só que agora com da vida ela
encontra a minha verdadeira natureza
aí ela fica aquele vazio olha pra minha
cara olha o cartão bota na luz né e uma
pegadinha e nem tem alguma coisa a ver
como é que eu te acho né pergunta meio
óbvia é fazer a chuva dando o cartão ou
na sua frente aqui não precisa me
procurar eu estou interessado em saber o
que a gente pode dialogar e criar a
partir desse momento do mistério porque
a ponte porque o vazio
então esse cartão tem acompanhado e sido
motivo de várias novas parcerias várias
novas conversas porque é um cartão
aberto para a possibilidade que está por
vir
o carro como avançava até então um
pouquinho sobre como é que esse vazio
tem feito parte da minha vida como é que
eu tenho me preenchido com coisas que me
importo fazendo fazendo o que eu posso
deixar de vídeo então algumas coisas
pertence a essa tela em branco quando
tinha 23 anos alguém falou pra mim até
acho que você vai curtir o mar chamada
ai que dor não tinha a menor idéia do
que ela foi lavrada uma portinha uma
sala no centro de são paulo e me
encantei à primeira vista pela metáfora
do f dohc sinaliza a idéia de
transformar situações de conflito em
situações de harmonia por meio do corpo
do contato é uma filosofia que você
pratica com o corpo
sinaliza a possibilidade da gente levar
a situações impossíveis a possíveis
situações possíveis a fáceis tornar
fácil negra antes então me tornei um
entusiasta trouxe aqui uma pequena
imagem sempre me dá pra quem não conhece
do que se trata essa linguagem
é hoje em dia têm impactado várias
universidades empresas falando de uma
metáfora que traz novas memórias sobre
liderança sobre educação sobre resolução
de conflitos sobre negociação sobre
empatia usando uma linguagem que ela não
trabalha só com cognitivo mas com o
corpo
vamos avançar hoje então minha vida tem
sido preenchida com muitos eventos
hoje eu vou levar como brasileiros e
separadas não sou japonês mas ocupou
espaço em mim essa história de trazer um
pouco de camaradagem de cooperação com o
mundo o que falta
e se essa qualidade de sentimento das
relações corporativas quanto é triviais
mas o povo desse branco
olha isso aqui é interessante estava na
tem os dez anos conheceu luiz de campos
numa cafeteria estava tomando café não
me apresentar eu estava na sala estava
muito envolvido com a temática da
educação pela experiência da educação
não formal o valor de conversa com luiz
nunes conversa com josé bueno ea gente
toma um café e vai tomar café e perigoso
gente vai tomar café vez surgem grandes
projectos num museu do café
se houvesse espaço aberto para ouvir o
que a pessoa traz e nem sempre uma
malinha sacolinha tiracolo ele trouxe um
mapa geógrafo luís
quem traz o mapa de são paulo nenhuma
novidade uma cidade com mais de 12
milhões de habitantes
mas ela é complexa com problemas
seríssimos né de sobrevivência de
trabalho de saneamento enfim mas ele me
traz um mapa em desenho um croqui que
até hoje aguarda por ele chocou demais
eu estava aberto a ver o que ele trazia
ele me trouxe uma cidade que a gente
aprender a não ver uma cidade repleta de
vinhos cobertos
nossa que devia ser ensinado no ensino
fundamental ea gente passa a vida
inteira sem saber que esses rios estão
lá ea notícia mais fácil estão vivos
vamos colocar aqueles morreram não eles
estão todos correndo longe do nosso
nossa percepção mais vivos a gente e nós
não suportamos essa potência de
informação criamos um movimento chamado
rios e ruas pra que sensibilizar milhões
de pessoas
ali a desejar em verem descobrirem
e quererem nossos rios de volta não é
pra cuidar daquilo que todo mundo
desconhece isso aí tem sido a nossa vida
nos últimos dez anos
coisa que não estava nenhum business
plan da minha vida trabalhar a temática
das águas
vamos avançar coisas que mauro sato -
atom e aparece alguns três anos atrás
disse presidentes de grandes agências de
propaganda ele chega em casa com um boné
me estranha aquilo e pegando mal porque
esse boné
a energia do boné fazer acabei de me
recuperar de um tumor que tinha na
cabeça
fui lá e isso me fez pensar na vida como
é que a gente está gastando nosso tempo
ele bateu na minha porta pra gente
conversar sobre a gente podia fazer
juntos uma grande amizade que a gente
crie uma iniciativa chamada 5070 vai
explorar esse território de nós estamos
vivendo
eu tô com 58 maio com 62 esse território
da maturidade da vida na maturidade da
maturidade na vida nos importa é a gente
ir lá pra cá tem feito uma série de
encontros pelo brasil em portugal
reunindo homens reunindo mulheres a
escolher a quem somos
quem é e se essa pessoa assim depois dos
como estamos com quem nós estamos o que
nós queremos e isso sempre levando
drogas né
leveza e simplicidade e diversão que a
gente não tá lá pra reclamar pra ficar
se lamuriando mas pra ver qual é o
potencial criativo nesse momento de vida
vamos lá arte e vê assim pensa que o
desenho faz tempo adoro desenhar a esse
exercício de observar deixar ser
acertado por uma imagem ea escutar meu
gesto de um papel numa numa tela mas
durante muitos anos eu comecei a
faculdade de arquitetura eu tive muita
vergonha de encostar lá com seu dever
com artistas muito mais talentosos do
que eu
muito mais competência e eu dei um passo
para trás jovem e foi desenhado depois
de 15 anos porque perdi a vergonha de me
expressar de contar uma história por
meio de um desenho e hoje faz parte
assim da minha da minha o meu mapa de
vida está sendo com um bloquinho tá
sempre explorando os jeitos de deixar
meus registos nesses brancos não podia
deixar de colocar aqui coisas que me
importa que preencher esse vazio
minha mulher meus dois filhos minha neta
as irmãs as pessoas mais próximas estão
ocupando esse dano ajudando a dar
sentido a esse período de vida que a
gente tem que muitos acham que é vazia e
sem sentido é papel nosso preencher esse
lugar e dar sentido essa história e
assim vai rolar já não queria gastar
muito tempo porque eu estou interessado
aqui em saber se você tem interesse em
abrir esse espaço vazio do espaço de
curiosidade um espaço de criança de
aprendiz de curioso no que você nem
sequer imagina que você pode ainda vir a
criar com as pessoas estão por perto de
você no lugar onde você vive ou talvez
em outro lugar porque a tivesse uma dica
para deixar aqui é eu sugeriria o
seguinte a gente vai sair daqui hoje ea
gente vai continuar sendo é atingido por
essas perguntas que você faz que você de
onde você é quem é você como seria a
dica aqui eu vou eu vou entregar pra
vocês no meu presente é o maior presente
aqui esse espaço em branco o espaço em
completo pra quê pra gente evitar filada
de uma resposta fácil de uma resposta
antiga e com certeza vai diminuir em a
gente é quem eu sou quem você é porque o
mundo precisa de gente como eu como
vocês cada vez mais gente criativa gente
criadora e espera um pouquinho mais sem
vergonha
ok obrigado
[Aplausos]